[Musique]
seulement 9% des entrepreneurs dans les
nouvelles technologies sont des femmes
et alors que 70% des femmes pensent que
l'entrepreneuriat est une vraie solution
intéressante par rapport au salariat
donc voilà c'est cette c'est ce chiffre
là qu'on a envie de changer qui est pas
normal être une femme entrepreneur ou
faire partie d'une équipe dirigeante en
tant que femme
avoir un projet innovant avoir un projet
impact et avoir déjà fait la preuve de
son concept il ya dix lauréates qui vont
bénéficier d'un accompagnement sur neuf
mois avec des accompagnements collectif
donc en groupe des formations en terme
commercial
et puis en terme de terme de financement
c'est les deux gros sujet en fait de
cette accélération
c'est la première année en fait tout le
programme est ouvert sur vraiment toute
la france
donc du coup la rue de saint germain
participent à cette ce programme d
ambitieuse de manière active à cette
année on serait ravis d'avoir au moins
une lauréate
voilà qui représente la rue saint
germain et qu'on irait volontiers dans
notre communauté de st